the opening scene begins with a couple
Truman and Patricia who are sleeping
peacefully until they hear an unfamiliar
sound suspecting that it is an intruder
that cautiously head downstairs only to
find a girl asleep on the couch under
the influence of Narcotics Truman
recognizes her as one of his clients who
had stayed over after a party the
previous night he wakes the girl up and
asks her to leave here we learn that
Truman is a struggling businessman who
keeps on hosting small parties at his
place in the hopes of Landing deals with
his clients later on Truman as usual
tells his wife to get the dinner ready
because he is going to invite a big
client Patricia seems to be upset by his
daily useless parties but this time
Truman believes that they will be able
to pay off all of their debts and
mortgages if he is able to make this
deal in addition Truman appears to have
impulsively bought an expensive car
solely to impress the client seeing this
Patricia becomes angry pointing out that
they already have enough debt to pay she
even wishes to work in some part-time
jobs but Truman does not want her to
work in the next scene we are introduced
to to an affluent businessman named Alex
Weston his wife Marina their son Robbie
and their houseworker Bell Alex and
Marina are so busy with their work that
they are unable to allocate time for any
household work not even for their son
one day Bell reminds them about their
son's birthday but the busy couple
simply asks her to wish him a happy
birthday on their behalf Robbie who
overhears their conversation is clearly
disheartened fortunately Belle cheers
him up by surprising him with a cake
along with a birthday gift next Robbie
heads for school and waits for the
arrival of his Crush Cheryl he
approaches her and asks her out for a
date sadly Cheryl politely declines his
offer saying that she is already seeing
someone this rejection saddens Robbie so
he decides to skip classes and drives
away later Alex becomes aware of this
and confronts Robbie at home he mentions
that he wants to enroll Robbie in the
best university and for this he must
secure good marks in school moreover
Alex seizes the car keys as a punishment
for his previous act the same evening
Truman invites his wealthy client Manson
over for dinner at his place he wants to
seal the deal as soon as possible but
Manson doesn't even pay attention to his
words this is because he is captivated
by Patricia's Beauty and he begins
flirting with her relentlessly he even
tries to touch her under her clothes
causing her to leave in Anger after a
while she confides in her husband about
the incident hoping for his support
however Truman simply tells her to
comply because the deal is very
important for them this leaves Patricia
with no option but to give herself in as
a result Truman lets Manson get intimate
with his wife just for the sake of the
deal the following morning Truman
arrives at the office where his
assistant informs him that the bosses
have been in a meeting with a man called
Alex a short while later he learns that
the deal which he had been working
tirelessly to secure has been handed
over to Alex Truman tries to persuade
his boss Mike but the latter claims that
Alex is renowned in this industry and is
a better addition to the company
devastated Truman returns home and
shares the news with Patricia who is
equally affected by the turn of events
the next day Truman prepares to go to
the office which surprises Patricia as
he typically does not work on Sundays
upon arriving he walks into his cabin
and commits the unthinkable out of
depression the cleaning lady hears The
Gunshot and rushes to check the source
only to be freaked out by the Grim sight
of Truman's death the news is soon
relayed to Patricia which leaves her
devastated a few days later Patricia
visits her husband's office and meets
with his boss Mike she inquires about
the insurance policy in Truman's name
but Mike coldly replies that the
insurance is invalid as Truman had
committed the unthinkable after a brief
conversation Patricia goes to her
husband's cabin to collect his
belongings during this she steals all
the crucial information from the
computer with a determined intention to
exact Vengeance for her husband's death
first of all Patricia drives to Mason's
residence and doesn't hesitate to shoot
him in broad daylight she then starts to
stalk Alex's activities and soon learns
about his son Robbie after this Patricia
follows Robbie to his school where she
poses as a concerned parent and obtains
a school letterhead later that night she
uses the letterhead to compose a letter
to Robbie's parents emphasizing the need
for a tutor in order to ensure Robbie's
academic success the next day Patricia
retrieves a phone call from Marina who
extends an invitation for a discussion
at their home Patricia disguises herself
as Amanda and visits Robbie's residence
upon her arrival the teen is immediately
struck by her beauty and wants her as
his tutor Marina inquires about the
potential start date for tutoring to
which she replies that she will need
some days because her house is currently
undergoing Renovations and that she has
to find a temporary home hearing this
Robbie mentions their guest house is a
place for her to stay Alex and Marina
agree with their son and offer Patricia
the guest home an offer she accepts
starting from the following day Patricia
goes to pick up Robbie from school while
wearing an alluring outfit as they
return to the guest house she begins her
tutoring sessions but Robbie is
infatuated by her all this time as days
pass by Patricia forms a friendship with
Marina in order to gather more
information about the family to gain her
trust she lends Marina a helping hand
with various tasks eventually Patricia
discovers that Marina has been consuming
pills to manage her anxiety armed with
this now knowledge she begins adding
narcotics to Marina's Coffee and Wine
gradually deteriorating her health one
night Robbie is playing basketball in
the backyard when he notices Patricia
changing her clothes in the guest house
intrigued he begins to spy on her
through the window Patricia spots his
actions but pretends to be unaware she
then starts touching herself with the
intention of arousing him just then
Belle catches Robbie in the act and
scolds him before taking him away the
following day Bell takes a day off from
work and goes for her personal errands
Alex and Marina are busy at their work
which leaves Robbie alone in the house
Patricia seizes this opportunity to
visit Robbie's room and warn him against
spying on her furthermore she tells him
that if he wants to look at something he
just needs to knock on her door and ask
for it acting upon the suggestion Robbie
excitedly follows her to her room there
Patricia tells him that she will teach
him everything she knows she then
encourages him to undress himself kisses
him and the two end up getting into an
intimate act the next morning Patricia
approaches Alex and engages in a
friendly conver conversation with him
after their brief exchange she returns
to a room only to discover Belle
installing blinds on her window sensing
that Belle might interfere with her
revenge plan Patricia decides to get rid
of the older woman one day when Bella is
alone at home attending to the laundry
Patricia discreetly enters the house and
makes her way to the basement in this
hidden space she crafts a trap using a
thin wire and removes the light bulb
sometime later Belle descends the
darkened staircase where she
unfortunately trips over the wire and
passes away in the evening Robbie
returns home from school and immediately
seeks Patricia to show his grades which
have surprisingly improved encouraged by
this positive news they share another
intimate moment not long after Marina
arrives home from work and calls out for
Bell when she doesn't receive any answer
she goes to check on her in the basement
and to her horror she finds Belle's
lifeless body there in the aftermath of
this tragic Discovery authorities handle
Bells remains while Marina struggles to
come to terms with the loss that night
Patricia approaches Alex who is engaged
in in a game of snooker seeing him upset
due to the recent events she walks
closer to him and attempts to seduce him
assuring to help him relax she then
bends by the pool table making Alex take
her from behind Okay this entire Affair
is spotted by Robbie through the window
so Patricia acts as if Alex is forcing
him to do so the next day she volunteers
to stay in Marina's care since Bella is
no more following her pattern Patricia
drugs Marina's coffee before serving it
to her she also contacts the pharmacy
assuming Marina's identity and requests
for more pills all of this contributes
to Marina's declining Health due to
pills afterwards Patricia visits
Robbie's room and apologizes for what he
had to witness earlier in the pool room
she deceitfully asserts that Alex
compelled her to do so fueling Robbie's
hatred towards his father even further
one day Patricia goes to Marina with
another coffee mixing the drugged
contents in it during their brief
conversation she mentions that our house
will be ready in a matter of days
indicating that she will leave in
response Marina thanks her for being
such a good friend and helping her this
entire time she then tries to get up
from her seat but suddenly experiences
dizziness at this moment Marina finally
notices something amiss with her coffee
and suspects Patricia's involvement that
night Robbie visits Patricia's room to
bid goodbye to her because he will be
leaving for his new out-of-state
University and will be staying in the
hostel as a result of this the two
engage in a passionate love-making act
for one last time the following
afternoon frobby departs for the airport
with one of his friends and Patricia
also leaves in her car as the evening
Dawns a heavy rainstorm sets in and
Marina who is all alone in her house
feels scared in order to intensify her
fear she receives unsettling phone calls
and also experiences power Cuts amidst
all this she hears a noise coming from
the basement equipping herself with a
knife she Ventures downstairs to
investigate at the same time Alex
returns home from work startling Marina
and nearly causing her to mistakenly
stab him following this she tries to
make Alex understand that Patricia is
evil but he brushes off her claims and
walks away in the morning before heading
to the office Alex notices Patricia's
car number and recalls having seen a
similar car driven by Truman upon
reaching the office he delves into
Truman's remaining belongings and
discovers a photograph featuring Truman
and Patricia fueled by concern he goes
to his boss Mike and the latter reveals
that Patricia is indeed Truman's wife
this sends Alex into a state of panic
and he desperately tries to contact
Marina when he fails to connect with her
he contacts the police and then rushes
to his wife's aide meanwhile at home
Patricia shows up in Marina's room with
a Sinister purpose of ending her life
she restrains Marina secures her to the
bed and forces her to ingest a pill
Patricia wants to kill her in such a way
that it will appear like a self-kill but
just as she is about to finish off the
poor woman Alex arrives in the nick of
time to intervene with her identity now
exposed Patricia boldly admits to all of
her actions thus far including her
physical relationship with their son
this angers Alex who then slaps her and
pushes her through the window after a
while the police arrive at the scene but
by the this time Patricia appears to
have fled the police helped the couple
to calm down ensuring their safety later
that night the couple receives a
reassuring call from their son who
shares that he is adjusting well to his
new environment after hanging up the
phone Robbie retreats to his bed where
Patricia is already waiting for him they
turn off the lights before sleeping
together subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching